n'importe qui a compris que notre pays
est dans un état de dégradation
sécuritaire important
bon ça c'est une chose c'est une
évidence il ya pas que les banlieues ya
pas de place bellecour à lyon ccd rodéo
ça n'arrête pas à tous les niveaux donc
que faire
il y a bien sûr des forces de police il
y a des forces de gendarmerie
territoriale il ya des forces de
gendarmerie mobile
il y a la garde nationale mais quand
tout cela il faut pas oublier que les
les forces armées comme les forces de
l'intérieur d'ailleurs sont organisées
il ya des ya déjà des plans il ya des
scénarios et il est tout à fait acter
enfin il est tout à fait décidé que dans
certaines conditions
si jamais le climat sécuritaire du pays
se dégrade est un point tel que les
forces de première et deuxième catégorie
c'est à dire plus tout l'effort civil
c'est-à-dire les forces de police les
forces de gendarmerie
les forces de la garde nationale ne
suffisait pas été débordée étaient
insuffisantes était dépassé et inadapté
et bien dans certaines conditions bien
sûr sous la direction du politique il
peut être décidé de faire appel à des
forces terrestres pour assurer la
protection des citoyens
donc si vous voulez je trouve que ce
soit on parle du climat sécuritaire on
prend cette tribune pour ce qu à mon
avis elle est alors évidemment c'est
dans un contexte politique et tout le
monde se jette dessus pour en faire son
miel mais c'est fort dommage
et ça ne règle pas le problème le
problème c'est un constat et c'est que
en fait je pense que ce qui a déplu
foncièrement souverainement au pouvoir
dans cette tribune c'est évidemment
c'est une apostrophe très directe au
pouvoir est une une
enfin là le doigt sur la plaie
[Musique]